[Music]  hello everyone a very Merry Christmas  and a Happy New Year from everybody here  at to play - I think this festive period  is a great time to spend with your  family to have good conversations good  food to give each other gifts and to  spend some time on the new level in age  27 in the play - app of course for me  personally 2017 has been has been an  interesting year  that's that's for sure chess wise there  have been ups and downs perhaps more  downs than I've been used to but I enjoy  the challenge  I enjoy looking forward to everything  that's 2018 it's gonna have to offer and  I I'm still looking forward to the world  record and blades championship starting  starting very soon well once again I  would like to just yeah wish you Merry  Christmas and all the best from  everybody here at our little company